so alienation from 1998 was going to get
a reboot a remake straight to cinema but
it's been delayed and got stuck in
development hell
now
it's planning to go straight to a
streaming service in a series
but there are lots of other projects
stuck in development hell that should
follow their example
welcome to sidetrack your scifi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
when james khan died a few months ago a
lot of people went on there and said
about remembering the movies that he'd
been in that they loved they remembered
elf and
gangster movies and things that he'd
done but i remembered alienation
the movie that for me inspired district
9
that great movie with a really unique
and original story
alienation went on to spawn a tv series
that only survived one series sadly but
became such a cult classic that it went
on to have five tv movies the writers of
iron man and the director jeff nichols
started to try to develop a movie reboot
of this back in 2015
but it's really struggled to get off the
blocks and then cove it happened
in the last few months jeff nichols who
is still signed on to direct this has
announced that it's still happening and
it's still moving forwards but it will
go straight to streaming it will be a 10
or 12 episode series instead now i would
argue that that is a very wise move in a
movie that's 90 minutes to two hours you
don't get the character development that
i think a story like alienation really
needs you need to get to know you need
to get to like and you need to get to
care about the characters for it to work
now this could start franchise where
they do sequel movies but just as easily
you could just do a streaming series
instead
now stream and series do get decent
budgets even though i do appreciate that
the streamer services are in a bit of a
mess at the moment they can't seem to
decide what to do then we've had a bit
of a golden period to the stream
services where they have lots of money
and lots of growth to invest in but that
growth is slowed or even stopped for
netflix they are rethinking a lot of
projects moving forwards but the
alienation project would be a reasonably
low budget thing it's a very high
concept series it has lots of social
commentary it has lots of different ways
you can do what sci-fi does best and
actually have layers to it and talk
about lots of different real life issues
through the metaphor alva alien cop
buddy series and if the series has the
same humor and joy that the movie did in
the following series did then there's no
reason why this couldn't be a massive
success
but there are lots of other projects
stuck in developmental that could do the
same for example for years now they've
been trying to do an 18 movie a sequel
to the movie a few years ago that kind
of bombed now i really hoped when liam
neeson stepped up to take on the moniker
of hannibal that that would lead to a
series of movies i thought it was a
brilliant idea i thought bradley cooper
as faceman was just genius casting and i
really hoped we would get two three four
movies out of it but it never happened
mainly because the movie just wasn't
that popular at the box office the
reason though for me was again this is a
character-driven project you need to
care about hannibal face mad murdoc and
ba and if you don't if you're not
invested in them it doesn't work
so again this is a project forget about
trying to make a movie you should be
making a streaming service series
knight rider has been in pre-production
for a few years now james 1 has got 31
projects currently on his imdb list of
upcoming from arachnophobia to mortal
kombat 2 to oh god the list just goes on
and on and on for me the knight rider
should not be a movie
if you do a movie it should just be
something that starts a new franchise
it should be something that goes
straight to amazon or netflix james one
producing this wants to make a cinematic
movie but
it feels like this kind of project
doesn't really suit a cinematic release
now there is a lot of nostalgia for
projects like knight rider and the
a-team people love these projects and
they love the originals they still watch
them today regularly
so with the ever-growing list of
projects that james one has signed
himself up to maybe he should reconsider
knight rider as a movie and instead pass
it on to somebody else that could
produce a series for amazon or netflix
or disney plus
people that would absolutely kill to get
a project like this on their service and
would be a far better project in the
long run
finally on my list of projects i've been
stuck in development health for years
and that would do with for me a shift
from a cinematic release to a streaming
service project instead is the spawn
movie
now jamie foxx has been signed on for
this for a couple of years and he keeps
talking about it it's definitely a
project he desperately wants to do
todd mcfarlane wants to write produce
direct and everything in this movie and
again he really really keeps talking
about how he wants this project to
happen but he wants it to become a
cinematic release because you can't
start franchises on streaming services
he says it just doesn't work you need a
cinematic release to kick start
something like this
i would argue that that's maybe a little
bit dated and even though spawn would
work as a cinematic release it just
would it's the type of movie that wasn't
done very well first time around jamie
foxx has been talking about how when
they saw the joker a movie with quite a
small budget that he sees the spawn
having a similar sort of vibe to that
and that's what him and todd mcfarlane
are talking about todd mcfarlane has
obviously considered the streaming
service approach he talks about it in an
interview a few months ago
but he dismisses it because like as he
said he wants to create the franchise i
would argue though that a franchise
gives you that time to develop a
character but so does a streamer service
you could get 10 hours of product
equivalent to 5 movies in one series on
a streaming series and you could get a
decent budget to do it so why not just
go that way if as i say in this case the
project just doesn't seem to be able to
get past the starting line i genuinely
believe the spawn would make a brilliant
cinematic release unlike the a-team at
knight rider where i think they need to
be streamer service because it's so
character-driven the spawn project isn't
quite like that but in this case where
it seems to be struggling so hard to get
going and if there is somebody like hbo
max out there willing to give you the
money to make a short series
go that way
get it done get the project made
or it'll just keep getting pushed back
and push back and eventually it just
will never happen i'd love to know
exactly what you think and if there are
any other projects that you think would
be much better as a streaming service
series than a cinematic release if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification it
really helps us out also you can
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button as always
guys please stay safe i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you